training in the park alone I realized to
myself how important Brotherhood was I
used to travel all the way down it's a
pearly and how and a half two hours
drive really from a Jew for now what my
clothes had holes in them and my afro is
picky to the night east maschino amis
Archie nice no laces inner Archie's new
millennium usually I go training boxing
but I can't
so therefore what I'm gonna do is
there's a park near my mom's house I'm
gonna go for a run there some people
some people fall ill internet houses
because there's not good bad bad
bacteria because their family get rid of
them excessive cleaning OCD I'm gonna do
that with a plate awesome now
uh sir I'm heading out on a call for a
job because staying at home I know other
people that go through the prayer that
have depression or mental illness or
different stuff it's not good to stay
home you're told to go out and now is
that you're told to stay in so if you go
in out fresh air
I'm gonna go for a job probably about
half an hour do some press ups in the
park or sign of that I have to because I
believe training the body it helps me
mentally as well to probably join me
let's go for a jog
yes guys I'm talking about yeah before
doing the run it's a short time my laces
it's very very important that we do our
at crash yeah so I'm gonna put the link
of an app cut up that was given to me
and it changed my life well that I used
to get really evil force
you know what mental healthier being how
and about it's related to it I see a
really bad ports really you know bad
stuff I went through mad face a couple
of about two years about two three years
ago where I felt like I was about to
lose my mind and was because I never
used to do might have car I know he
stated that seriously and I miss do my
sky properly so that's why I wonder
up there but there's some key ones that
you can do bismillah Hill Adelia to room
as me show you feel are they well FSMA
what was similarly you can do that and
also for a good protection for the body
for that hearing for the side our side
allahumma - if you bet any Allah who
magnificent me a lot my friend if it
busts that Allah can do that three times
also you can do one seven times it's a
piece that has to be Allah Allah Allah
in the hawala hit our cult over water
pollution I think you do that seven
times and there's many more inertia and
water conditions are there so make sure
you do those very important especially
after you think awesome take me much and
when you guys doing jogging and running
it's very important while riding we've
got absolutely nothing the law lose the
Prophet sallallahu wasallam said dude
it's my on the tongue and heavy on the
day judgment of the deer on the scale so
that's running yeah you can do one of
these stuff so yeah you know I'm not
used to jogging outside how do the job
on the treadmill so it's quite
interesting it's a bit different so whoa
five minutes should I be on the swing
and probably try to do some Dumbo Club
yeah I might use that to do some dumb
bell curves
training in the park alone I realize to
myself how important Brotherhood was I
used to travel all the way down to
Pearlie and how in a half two hours
drive just to train with the brothers
just being around the company being
reminded of Allah support Allah this
thank him deep for me when I was
training alone
and they should make us reflect our
Brotherhood that we have
my other chucks with boobs indeed need
washing so I'm gonna go for the shovel
for this one for this one mm-hmm
I'm gonna go for this one I'm gonna go
for this one here yes
it's indeed indeed ready we ready now
okay so just pray Maghrib I'm gonna head
out just a quick reminder the prophet
sallallaahu was seldom said anybody that
praised their Farzana and recites ayatul
kursi the only thing that is between
them and Jenna is death meaning once
you've recited of course after the parts
are the only thing that stopping you
from go and paradise is dying to my
grandma's because there's a possibility
that she might have the virus therefore
I need to drop one extent impossible
outside I'm going to pick it up and I
can't even seen see my grandmother it's
sad you know
so guys grandmas she needs to call my
auntie to tell it to leave the stuff
outside okay this is a serious moment
yeah
[Music]
yes I'm in Edmonton so I came cause my
auntie is feeling better
and the doctor said that she needs to
have food nutrients to overcome it and
be to her immune system Lisa get back
just you know back running
she said she's craving doner kebab I
thought that's not a good idea ask talk
to my auntie but she says she's craving
it you know and she's not that well
obviously if she wants it we'll get it
mophir got some fruits and other stuff
is Rover did you hear what that guy just
said yeah so guys I'm just walking down
the road I'm on the phone and this guy
just rolled up at me and I'm thinking
I'm swearing on cash machine and then he
goes that tracks is hard Sam where did
you get that from
indeed indeed he gave me look I'm
telling you round it's indeed indeed
even they know the ones were speaking on
phone okay I think I dunno chopper bad
come get my favourite chocolate
so guys I've got my masks last one yeah
no my auntie's here dude how do I get it
so the hospitals are empty I'll cut up
or empty for now how you gonna touch
look have you touch this but be careful
found him hey such a look how do they
have these footprint people unless we
face the wall what was the scary face of
danila how many people's lives in here
do we learn lessons nope
[Music]
[Music]
like remember my mom asked for some
Turkish coffee so obviously I went to
test goes to look for some eggs couldn't
find it then I was at oh forget it I'll
get it tomorrow
then I thought to myself you know what
Andy this is your mom you get only one
mother she just wants a coffee she
doesn't want you to climb a mountain see
that's important because I'll see the
little bit lazy yeah and mom's not
feeling that well she just wants coffee
you know what have I got to do nothing
what I did is a little u-turn and Here I
am
try the shop and I'm gonna see if they
have one Jenna I'm telling you you lost
the Jenna so guys that's the end of the
blog today had a few things to do ah yes
so now I'm gonna stay in my room to them
for a next look Korona blog alright
don't forget to pray Ayesha